when you work to make things that other
people need you relieve dire dire needs
and that's a moral imperative in a world
in which 80% of the people are living on
less than $2 a day human beings are not
concerned with just the truth they're
concerned with relevance and this is
because of uh very powerful facts about
agency in the world the reason we
haven't solved all the theoretical
problems is that the math is equally
complex it's just not Material you can't
see it you see I think that one of the
troubles is that the term AI is just
misleading it's not artificial
intelligence 24/7 we can get cupcakes
cocaine and pornography uh whenever we
want we've been engaged in perhaps what
you might call war on empathy and so
when I went to the Soviet Union I made
thought oh this is just like home all
the big killings were not done by
private that perverts who did it for fun
they were done for the good of the
nation in in the highest
moral
D I tend to agree with you this kind of
you know good and then what doesn't fit
it is evil but now comes to me a key
question I think you Rowan were aiming
also in a different way at it but uh
those who protest the predominant form
of good in a certain Society like women
or slaves in a patriarchal society do we
necessarily have to use the categories
of Good and
Evil uh to protest like this would be
the classical criticism no where you say
sorry you are saying you are good but I
can show how you are
inconsistent that it's not really good
it produces evil effects and so on and
so on so is for you if good is what is
defined in the terms of predominant m
whatever is resistance to
good necessary put in the same terms so
good versus evil or can we say and I
don't think we can maybe in some
versions of reference to n that there
can be resistance which is not in itself
morally grounded that was the Dream from
nature to the L to the L and so on and
so on just to conclude then I will be
shorter the third things that's what I
want to do think I want to complicate
things that is to say as you said
correctly my God all the big killings
when were not done by private perverts
who did it for fun they were done for
the good of the nation in in the highest
moral terms so I think that uh the best
argument against absolutization of any
form of the good it's not just the
historicist one it's relative it's also
to point out with an imminent critique
how that form of uh good prod uces
necessarily catastrophic consequences
like to conclude and then I will speak
less to Rowan he's one of my eternal
books it's like I'm almost tempted to
say like uh ilot Homer sofocles Dante
Shakespeare and Ran's book on dooi where
you know he does something incredible
Doo's idiot is usually PL too good for
this world you know pure and so on now
no he's really a catastrophic idiot he
does something horrible by being good in
the wrong way and so on he causes only
catastrophe around himself look what
happens to Nastasia philipova do other
you cannot say they are in themselves
evil it's that idiot Prince mishkin
triggers he's good in a deeply wrong way
the best the most evil intentions can
sorry evil acts can be justified by a
certain form of evil uh sorry can lead
to evil consequences and that's crucial
today everybody wants to be extremely
good the worst of Nazis the worst of
stalinism they were full of common good
and so on and so on that recognition
that that that there is something there
that I think is important about two
entirely different ways of attending to
the world the prime difference between
the hemispheres is the kind of attention
they pay and I'm not going to take up a
lot of time on the hemisphere hypothesis
but what is important is that the left
hemisphere um sees these fixed things
that the camera was photographing as you
refer to so granular atomistic isolated
decontextualized abstracted fixed
whereas the right hemisphere sees that
in reality everything is connected
ultimately to everything else that it's
never completely fixed or known or
certain is knowable and we can have
greater degrees of certainty and truth
about it but it is not a final thing
that exists out there it is comes from a
relationship and this is the really key
thing I argue in the matter of things
that relationships are what the universe
is made of and that the relata the
things that are related emerge secondary
from from the web of relationships I
know that sounds paradoxical but we
haven't time to to to go into that
perhaps too much but the point there is
that things only become what they are
those things we think we see because of
where they're situated in relation to
everything else and the full context in
which they inhere and so that perception
changes the way we think of knowledge
it's not that there's stuff out there
that we can more Faithfully or other
otherwise record simply passively it's
something about if we really want to
know it we have to enter into a
relationship with
it and that means that something of us
goes into the experience of whatever it
is we experience no surprises in that
but it does not I emphatically insist
does not lead anywhere near a sort of
postmodern belief that we all just make
it up I I resist that with every fiber
of my being I think instead we have a
task a duty which is to follow
truthfully our intuitions where they
where they seem to be testable and true
in experience of life and that there is
a truth but it is something that we
approach in a spirit of approximation
and and Trust in a relationship you
trust the other and trust and Truth have
the same origin so I believe that
whatever it is that we know and
experience ultimately comes out of
relationships and of course
in the Christian religion but also in
other religions the ground of being
whatever word one uses to describe that
is love and love is nothing except a
relation I was proposing that the
distinction between the Supernatural and
the natural is a kind of reifying of a
Two Worlds mythology that we inherited
from the axial age and it's been with us
so long that we come to think of that as
the default way in which we should try
to understand and express people's
experience of the sacred and I'll I'll
use that as neutrally as I possibly can
something that they find really real
that calls them to transformation in
some fashion that I'm just going to put
it that we can talk about that but and
what what what I see and I know I'm not
pinning Sophie to being just a a voice
of Vicken Stein so I'm addressing Vicken
Stein not not Sophie um I think Vicken
Stein of course uh that you can see the
tractatus as being bound up with this
project of somehow can we find logic as
the Third Realm between the subjective
and the objective and Russell of course
is in that project and frga too um and I
think that project both in the analytic
and the Continental tradition and
there's a lot of argument to this but I
think that project has largely collapsed
um and a lot of the distinctions that
made that project sort of viable um have
have have collapsed and I think Vicken
Stein also was preent about this uh
because of course the investigations
represents an alternative
reinterpretation
um and so I'll I'll throw another quote
out uh which also has a mystical sound
to it because it puts you into silence
but a different way even if the lion
could speak we could not understand him
because what he's pointing to and what I
would interpret he's trying to get at in
the investigation and his whole theory
of use is that there all are there
actually multiple kinds of knowing there
isn't just propositional there's
procedural there's skills there's
perspectival what it is like to be in a
particular situation there's
participatory which is knowing by how
your identity is taking shape and these
are all interwoven together and that
this has to do with something that is as
important as Truth uh which now I'll say
something that is provocative but it's
at the core of my career which is human
beings are not concerned with just the
truth they're concerned with relevance
and this is because of uh very powerful
facts about agency in the world uh you
can't pay attention to all of the
information that's available to you you
can't pay attention to all the
information in long-term memory all the
different sequences of behavior
accommodator explosive the number of
possible moves in even a chess game uh
outnumbers the number of atomic
particles in the universe so one of the
projects I've been engaged in at at core
of AGI is how do you get a system to
zero in on relevant information and this
is what you can't get the system to do
check everything to see if it's relevant
so that means that human beings are
doing this you're all doing it right now
you're zeroing on on relevant
information things are obvious to you
obviousness is not part of physics but
if you don't have a capacity for finding
things obvious you can't do any problem
solving you can't do any knowledge
generation so this finding things
relevant this is what he means about the
lion the lion has a different form of
life it's a different biological
organism so what it finds relevant and
Salient is going to be very different
from us so even if it speaks English
correctly there might be you know truth
content there but we won't get the
relevance realization of the lion and we
won't be able to connect to the world
the way the lion does and I think that
what people are often seeking when
they're seeking belonging and meaning
and this is what the research shows we
we tend to think of it as purpose um
purpose is only one of the four
dimensions right there's purpose there's
coherence um there's significance and
there ma there's mattering and mattering
seems to be the one that matters most
that pun is intended uh which is people
want to feel that they're connected to
something
that has a reality and a a value beyond
their own egocentric existence and
perspective um Susan Wolf did some
excellent work on this and I think that
is because we are not just seeking truth
we are seeking to be connected to it in
a relevance realizing way and um I think
what people are therefore looking for
are not propos just propositions or
primarily
[Music]
propositions
in the past almost everybody was
desperately poor before the productivity
revolution in 1800 80% of the world's
population lived on the equivalent of
less than $2 a day just in material
deprivation that's hard to imagine um
the productivity Revolution is what
ended that and it ended that by thinking
of work in a particular way this is my
second Point Adam Smith says near the
end of The Wealth of Nations that the
only purpose of production is
consumption and in a world in which
almost everybody is desperately poor
that principle has a kind of a grim
moral logic because when you work to
make things that other people need you
relieve dire dire needs and that's a
moral imperative in a world in which 80%
of the people are living on less than $2
a day um second point though is
that the ability to flourish by
consuming material stuff is bounded in
our lives we can consume only so much
before we get sad and at some point of
every good and even money more no longer
makes us better off that point is
studied now actually by social
psychologists and we are nearer to it
than we think uh in the United States
today GDP per capita is high enough that
in principle if there were no inequality
effectively every us American could have
enough stuff produced by production with
the sole aim of consumption to satisfy
every material need that can make a
human life go better so we are reaching
the point at which the drive for
productivity is receding from its moral
imperative at the same time more and
more production is harming the planet in
a variety of ways and harming our
society um we're exploiting ourselves to
work harder and in More instrumental
ways and the planet can't bear much more
output and there is a kind of grim logic
of our age which is that productivity
Grows by exponential increase but if
efficiencies grow by exponential decay
and the more efficient you get the less
waste there is Left To Save By
efficiency but the more you produce the
more an additional increment of
productivity will produce and also waste
so the logic is such that productivity
is going to have to end its growth at
some point soon and the final point I
want to just end on is that leads us to
have to ask a very fundamental question
which is what is the purpose of work
when Smith's Mantra has outlived its
usefulness what is the point of
production when we have enough or even
too much consumption and how should we
structure our work lives so that work is
not a technology to productivity but a
process that is valuable in itself
what's it like to work individually to
make meaning in our lives and what's it
like to work together so that the
workplace becomes a site of community of
democratic collaboration and is valuable
in the doing of the job rather than for
the output Martin for for significant
proportion of people then Daniel's
asking uh saying we shouldn't be
pursuing productivity would you
agree up to a point um a lot of up to a
points on the panel I I I will do my
best to clarify our positions well I
tend to think that this is where I've
ended up now in my late '70s that most
of Life consists of painful tradeoffs
without simple answers I hate to say
that and I'm not going to change that
view just because you'd like me to
because the tendency of some people to
regard all the material and Associated
progress of the last 200 years as a
snare and delusion is a pretty mildly a
very serious mistake among other things
about 80% of you would not be alive the
population growth obviously is a
function of that one of the problems
creating success creates problems uh and
um in addition to the bottom billion who
are borderline destitute the sort of
people who as a result of covid in the
disruption of covid have died in very
large numbers which we don't think about
I've written about this so poverty
matters right and the ability to cope
with trauma like covid for societies was
immeasurably increased by the fact that
we're just so rich we could do something
I'm not saying it was wise not we
couldn't even imagined before which was
in response to a major disease closed
down large parts of the economy and stay
at home that's because we were so rich
productive and other countries couldn't
and I would say something like 3/4 to
80% of humanity and that will be
consistent with Daniel's figures are
still in the the realm in which higher
output per head will make a great deal
of difference the second point I would
make is even if we don't want
productivity behead in aggregate we
still need a hell of a lot of innovation
which is really what productivity is
about to me it it's the ability to do
more with less well what's interesting
about um the US the UK and the then
Soviet Union and now Russia which most
people probably wouldn't have picked up
on quite away but I think it sometimes
it's you know if you come from a
different vantage point you see things
that others don't I mean all of us again
will have had that experience is that
they're going through the same kind of
industrial transitions in roughly the
same um amount of time so I mean they're
the three of the greatest um industrial
powers of course you know the Soviet was
all done by Central planning and you
know forced industrialization goolag
labor you know the whole thing here
which was wasn't quite the same in the
United States and the UK though I think
you know we can also say things were
very harsh you know for workers at
different points but they start to go
into decline industrial declining around
the same time and of course the Soviet
Union is the ultimate land of Big Smoke
Stack factories factories and workers
you know the state of factories and
workers and it's subsidizing everything
so you know the the disaster is staved
off a lot longer than it is in the UK
and in the United States but one thing
that I isn't fully appreciate in the UK
the whole north of England in the
Midlands is all in is all um
nationalized in a way that it isn't
really you know down here in the South
because after World War II all of the
businesses were you know basically on
the verge of bankruptcy having been cut
off from the rest of the world economy
for five months and all the big
industrialists the kind of people that
you would have heard of in the past the
Vickers the Armstrongs Fess I mean these
are all Bells all these are kind of
names you'll read in a history book um
they all disappear and instead you got
British steel British coal British Rail
when I was growing up I didn't know
anybody who didn't work for the state
one way or another and so when I went to
the Soviet Union I iMed thought oh this
is just like home you know everybody
works for the the the government you
know one way or another day my dad
worked for British coal and he went
briefly for British steel and he went
for the National Health Service my
mother was a midwife in the National
Health Service I the only people I knew
had their own business were you know
plumo the local electrician or the
people in the corner Shore so you know
you've got a kind of a a different
perspective going up in in an area like
that and so you know the Soviet Union of
course the the Bolshevik Revolution
removes any kind of private property but
there wasn't really any private property
beforehand and then when I went to the
United States of course you think
something would be completely different
because you don't have any
nationalization after World War II un6
but you do have these huge steel plants
and coal mines and uh car manufacturing
and all of the people's lives and
Welfare are tied up with that as well
because I'm sure you're all aware that
you know there's there's no Health
Service in uh the United States is all
tied to the workplace which also was a
feature of World War II and it was to
stop people from moving from place to
place in their in their factories and to
keep wages down during the war so in a
way with what Americans are really
thinking about it their workers become
indentured or trapped into their
workplace which is just what you have
the Soviet Union and you know you have
you know in the United Kingdom to some
degree so when all of the big industri
is going to decline because of you know
the global Trends work there suddenly
find themselves totally dislocated and
in the case of the United States they
lose their all their benefits they lose
their health care they also you know the
same as you know here in the UK you know
they they luse all of the amenities all
the Leisure it's all tied to those you
know the beem steel works or something
like this as well so they go through
that same pattern as well just in a
slightly different timee now you don't
notice in the US because what people
used to move around but you get these
incredible pockets of poverty and
deprivation in places like Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania the whole Appalachia which
is just like the Northeast it's like the
donbas and and the kbass and all these
areas and urals in um the Soviet Union
and in Russia Putin becomes the product
of this post-industrial collapse in the
1990s the shock therapy which is very
much like the you know the whole
privatization in the 1980s here in the
UK which all happened at once and lots
of people out of work and Putin you know
basically comes on into power in 1999
saying I'm going to make Russia Great
again sounds familiar right and he's
well I don't think he's made it great
but you know he's certainly done
something to it in the last um 23 years
that he's been in power in you know the
UK of course we you know with with
brexit and all the debates over this it
it people suddenly started to realize
that whole swears of the United Kingdom
felt completely left behind because in
the northeast of England immense
grievance that was being expressed in
the brexit vote not for Take Back
Control and sovereignty but more like
nobody's being developing here nobody's
been investing here you know for the
last 30 40 years we're told that it's
all CU all the money is going to
Brussels so now what's going to happen
which is why leveling up is now on the
agenda but you know people in my family
said well all the money's going to
Brussels that's why you know we have no
factories or we've got no jobs and
things there I'm just putting it a bit
crudely but that's kind of the way that
some people saw this what they were
being told exactly and then in you know
the United States people are being told
by your jobs have gone to China or
they've gone to Mexico that's actually
is true in many respects because of
their whole Global shifts but they're
also feeling out they're being left
behind and nobody cares about them
anymore so Along Comes Trump he's going
to make him America great again and he
wins election in 2016 by a margin of 70
to 77,000 votes in Three Counties in
three states Ohio Michigan and Wisconsin
all of which they've gone through
exactly the same post-industrial decline
but parts of uh Russia and uh the United
Kingdom have gone through and it's the
same sense of grievance when you go to
talk to people as you you know you hear
in those places
[Music]
too
so we reflexively approach pleasure and
avoid pain we don't have to think about
that that is how we are innately wired
over millions of years of evolution in
fact we have to think about doing the
opposite so it's not a matter of should
we abandon this reflex we are we have
limited capacity although some capacity
to do so what's at issue here is the
ways in which this ancient wiring which
has us reflexively approaching pleasure
and avoiding pain is mismatched for the
modern ecosystem in which almost every
aspect of human life has become drug
aied in some way or another what do I
mean by drug aied I mean made more
reinforcing releases more dopamine in
our brains reward pathway made more
ubiquitous easier to access meaning that
247 we can get cupcakes cocaine and
pornography uh whenever we want um and
also made a more novel so more novel by
adding new molecules to Old drugs by
combining uh Behavioral or processed
drugs like um singing and a competition
an American Idol making all of our Lives
now reinforcing in fact you might even
argue that the Dark Side of successful
capitalism is to turn us all into
addicts so therefore because our ancient
wiring is mismatched for this modern
ecosystem we now have a new mandate a
new and unprecedent ented mandate where
we have to intentionally insulate
ourselves from these reinforcing stimuli
in order to be in balance with our
ancient wiring with our bodies with this
ecosystem and if we don't do that if we
relentlessly pursue pleasure at it as it
seems we are doing now especially in
Rich Nations we will end up in this
dopamine deficit state which is our
neurological response uh in the process
of becoming addicted and we will end up
more depressed more anxious um and
overall less happy with our lives a very
interesting Trend with happiness surveys
was that prior to about 2000 as wealth
increased in a given Nation happiness
went up but starting about 20 years ago
uh in those same countries uh happiness
started to go down and so I really do
think it does beg the question even if
especially since it's purely subjective
what is happening there what's the
phenomenon I would 100% agree that
dopamine is not some you know simple um
process and then you can say dopamine
equals pleasure and in fact I don't say
that in my book and I never have said
that you know dopamine is a a
neurotransmitter That's essential for
the experience of pleasure
and yes it is if you don't like the
subjectivity measure um that comes
inherently with measuring people's
depression or anxiety or happiness
levels then let's look at death and if
you don't like deaths of Despair let's
look at Global deaths so some 60 to 70%
of global deaths today are caused by
diseases that are due to modifiable risk
factors the top three are obesity the
second one is being sedentary and the
third is smoking so the point here is
that we are now dying in unprecedented
numbers from lifestyle diseases the
number one killer is no longer in
infectious diseases okay covid
notwithstanding for a brief period of
time or cancer or or accidents uh it's
people essentially killing themselves
through their behaviors and it's not fun
this is not about going to Grandma's
house and having too much fun I I wish
that it were uh this is about people who
are really really miserable and who
really have lost some degree of autonomy
because of the way that these potent
reinforcers hijack our reward system
polit there's a thing I haven't thought
about for a long time it's a word that
doesn't really uh come up much in
society and I think partly the reason
for that is is for perhaps the last 20
years uh we've been using a different
word for politeness we've been calling
it political
correctness and we've been engaged in
perhaps what you might call war on
empathy anybody who shows politeness uh
or are careful in what they say is
castigated as uh as weak or uh uh virtue
signaling and
consequently um those kind of ideas of
politeness have been uh um pushed to the
back of our culture and it troubles me
greatly because I'm in the empathy
business
music is all about empathy it's the
currency of what we do music is trying
to get you to feel something for uh an
emotion for something you yourself may
not have encountered or perhaps you draw
some empathy from the music itself so to
see empathy castigated in such a way by
people who use terms like political
correctness when really that what
they're talking about is is uh
politeness really really troubles me
because everybody fundamentally has the
right to be treated with dignity and
respect whatever their position you know
in debate that can change as has always
been already been mentioned by s it
sometimes you do have to uh take people
on but our starting point has to be one
of dignity and respect but that does
need to touch on a little bit more about
what we're going to move on to
later sometimes that does need to
be if not enforced then at least given
some parameters last week in London the
national conservative conference took
place the uh the Nazis as we call them
and uh they uh
they were talking a lot about freedom of
speech which they saw as a fundamental
good and very often the people who were
talking about it were the very people
who use the term political correctness
over the last few decades and their uh
idea of uh the parameters of free speech
it has to have some kind of parameters
uh they saw the parameters of free
speech as being
Duty and responsibility
and I have a little bit of a problem
with that because I think responsibility
Duty you're relying on the individual to
mark their own homework you know
being uh we we say we take
responsibility uh implies that it's
something that we ourselves belongs to
us ourselves to uh take that step rather
than be encouraged to do it whereas when
we say we hold someone to account we're
suggesting the ability of someone
outside of the individual having uh uh
some uh control over that person and
what they say and I think that part of
the problem that we have with the lack
of politeness is to do with the lack of
accountability most obviously online
most obviously um in our social media
discourse uh there are no parameters
there whatsoever and what parameters
there were on Twitter have now been
thrown away by the Free Speech
absolutist uh Elon Musk
and so I think the balance between free
speech and uh uh accountability is out
of whack and I think if we could find a
way to bring accountability back into
balance with free speech that would uh
in effect bring politeness uh back into
our into our cultural discourse perhaps
not just online but all the way uh to
the very top uh to uh our our those who
govern
us
[Music]
I like many string theorists think that
we live once I'm not interested in
spending my time on a theory that's
wrong and so being able to make that
experimental judgment is is would be
wonderful we can't do it yet I agree
with that but that's not some
fundamental failing of the theory it's
the failing of us theorists to
understand the theory well enough to
make those predi itions final point I
will make is in terms of connection to
physics and there are others that I
could bring up but let me just focus on
one we've known Roger of course since
the work of you work of Stephen Hawking
about for instance black hole
entropy and string theory is still the
only framework within which we can
calculate from first principles for a
certain category of black holes and
reproduce the beautiful formula that
Stephen Hawking wrote down in terms of
the area of the vent Horizon divided by
four and so there's a wonderful
connection between equality of the world
that I think many of us agree is correct
that black holes have entropy governed
by the area of the Event Horizon and
string theories calculation from first
principles for certain categories of
black holes of that number so that again
among many other things that we could
discuss are links to physics so I'm a
little surprised that you would say
there's no connection to physics but
perhaps I'll leave it there and happy to
hear your response I I think we would
all love to see the experimental
verification it's just a a technical
issue of reaching those energies um
and I think there's no string theorist
who would not want verification and I
don't know of any string theorist who
says it's not needed right we we all
agree that that is what we're working
towards we just think it's going to take
a lot longer than usual to get there and
to that point I just want to say I mean
we're used to thinking that these
experimental um I don't I don't even
know what to call them devices apparatus
I mean something as huge as ligo or U
you know the the colliders at CERN we
can see what goes into them right we see
how finely they have to be calibrated we
see the amount of material they take so
it's easy for us to see how complicated
they are I just want to suggest that the
the reason we haven't solved all the
theoretical problems is that the math is
equally complex it's just not Material
you can't see it but there's a lot of
things that have to be literally as
finely tuned as that ligo laser beam um
there's a lot of matths that has to be
developed there's a lot of Frameworks
that you know we need to come up with um
string theory is sort of forcing us to
to develop all of these things it's not
they're not pre-existing so yes it's
taking time um and I think those of us
who are motivated by it are willing to
give it that time I understand so the
the theory calls for 10 Dimensions maybe
six of them have to get rolled up they
have a very small diameter that means
that you're going to take a lot of
energy to excite it which means that
there's an energy threshold uh Beyond
which you hope that you can make
predictions but we haven't gotten there
yet that would apply to every other
theory that might be a rival to string
theory but if you try to tell string
theorists hey I have a different Theory
it makes particle predictions it says
exactly what the su3 cross su2 cross U1
quantum numbers are they'll say at what
energy level and you say I don't know
and they'll say well then it's not a
prediction it's not your theory is not
real and you say well you just pulled a
maneuver much worse than that you won't
even tell me what those things are and
so you have to understand how this game
is actually played the fact is is that
string theorists will always tell you
that if the better Theory came along
that they would immediately move to it
but what do you think about this modern
stuff going on about Ai and
people
they can they can create things by using
these AI devices do you have a comment
to make on that well I I just find it
it's so hard to sort of understand and
believe in something that to me doesn't
seem real but I feel if there was some
other member of our panel who was maybe
in their teens or 20s they might be the
one to answer it for me I I just don't
understand it enough when you've Ed the
right word in my view the word is
understand but these devices don't
understand a thing and so that they can
do some imitation of of conversation or
something like that and you realize
after a while it doesn't understand
anything not what it's talking about but
it's a very difficult concept to to
grasp the notion of understanding for
several hundred years we've been making
better and better simul simulacra of
human beings they started with very in
the 18th century rigid looking
mechanisms and just got a hell of a lot
better at it but it's asymptotic you you
you get closer and closer to what you're
thinking of but you never achieve it
because you're just doing a better and
better mockup which isn't what it is
that you're what we are well the thing
is it's not conscious absolutely my view
that's the trouble these devices quite
important so these devices don't well
you have to have a view about what you
think Consciousness is which I have and
I don't think I should B people about
that but the thing is these devices as
currently constructed would not in any
stretch of my imagination anyway become
conscious and that you can ascertain
this fact in in conversation with the D
you after a while look it doesn't have a
faintest idea what it's talking about it
come up with phrases a lot of knowledge
there you see I think that one of the
troubles is that the term
AI is just misleading it's not
artificial intelligence it's AR arcial
cleverness or knowledge knowledge I say
AI stands for artificial information
processing has nothing to do with
intelligence I completely agree with you
all creativity in fact all creativity
maybe the individual subtlety of
people's own individual brains and that
that's what's missing well that's
certainly what it always feels like yes
yes there was somebody who in the ' 80s
produced a computer that by feeding all
of the works of bark into it it could
produce a simulacrum of a work by bar
Mar but the great thing about Mark was
that he wasn't a simulacrum of anything
his very first composition at the age of
19 is staggering for its originality and
is
completely today one of the most moving
pieces of music he wrote so we really
mustn't mix human beings up with
machines organisms are not machines but
what I loved was when you said something
about I I in in my 20s I almost wrote a
book called against Perfection or In
Praise of imp Perfection but what is so
important is this non-completion the the
openness of something that is ever
ongoing in its
creativity and you when you said those
sort of incompleteness or gaps I then
thought well if there were no gaps to
coin a phrase how would the light get
[Music]
in